okay hi everybody I'm Kirsty Nathu I'm
one of the partners at Y Combinator and
it is my great honor to introduce Shanna
Lynn MA who's the CEO of Zola and Zola
has reinvented the wedding gift registry
and they've now worked with hundreds of
thousands of different couples and has
latest reported valuations for the
company of over 600 million dollars so
welcome so I gave a brief description
there of what you do but I'm sure you do
it a hundred times better than me so why
don't you say a little bit more about
what it is and what brought you to that
point sure maybe I can start by getting
a show of hands of who here has used Ola
either as someone getting married or
someone going to a wedding great well
thank you to you all and and for those
of you who aren't as familiar Zola is
the fastest growing wedding registry and
also one of the fastest growing wedding
companies and e-commerce sites in the
country we use design and technology to
really reimagine what it's like for
couples getting married today to plan
their entire wedding and we look to
serve couples from the day they get
engaged through that first year of
marriage people getting married today
the millennial generation and they're
unlike any other generation they want
different things and so we are really
the only place where couples can
register for things they truly want no
matter who they are where they live or
whatever device they live on and so what
drew you to weddings well like many
successful startups we started Zola
really out of personal need so 2013
which was the year that I started out
with my co-founder that was also the
year that all my best friends were
getting married at exactly the same time
yeah so I'm like many of us have had
that year here and you're going to a lot
of weddings and you're buying a lot of
gifts from really painful wedding
registries often so I was doing that in
2013 and I was so frustrated because my
friends were registered at the
traditional department store registries
and I had worked in e-commerce for a
long time and I thought that buying from
their registries was the most painful
ecommerce shopping experience I had ever
seen I started talking to my co-founder
at Nobu who was the head of the user
experience design team at gilt and we
had worked together at gilt for a very
long time and he's married and he
started complaining about how bad it was
from the couple side where he really
wanted to register for not just products
but experiences and cash he couldn't do
that he wanted to enable group gifting
he couldn't do that he wanted to
personalize his registry you couldn't do
that and so the more we talked about it
the more we realized this was an
opportunity and we were the best
possible people to solve it and so what
was this about it that made you jump
into being a founder from you know a
relatively stable job and everything
else to make you take that that leap
into the unknown well my background and
my co-founders background is really in
product management so we went through a
very traditional product development
process before we decided we really
wanted to commit to doing this 24/7 and
the process was we would start to talk
to any engaged person that we could find
any friend or friend of a friend we
would meet them understand their
experience their pain points and then go
away and try to design and innovate on
how we could improve their wedding
registry experience so in 2013 we
thought there's really three things that
kept coming up again and again couples
really do want to register for products
and experiences and cash all in the one
registry could
do that anywhere else couples secondly
really do want to fully personalise
their registry couldn't do that anywhere
else and in a world where on average in
the country people spend thirty five
thousand dollars on one wedding day
which is the average yearly income they
really care what it looks like and they
want the registry to reflect that and in
third we heard again and again the worst
part about registry from couples was
they wanted to control when their gifts
was sent to them and they didn't want to
receive anything before they were ready
and for most couples this actually means
they don't want anything until after
their wedding date so we started
designing this concept for zola based on
these three differentiators we would put
prototypes in front of users we would
ask them to walk us through the designs
and over the course of a few months we
would wait and try not to sell them or
leave them
we would wait for the brides to be to
ask us the magic question which is in
the product world it is when can I use
this product and it's really hard
because you really want to pitch them on
how great your product is but we tried
not to and we didn't hear that for a few
months and was only after we started to
hear brides who were getting married the
following year say to us will this be
ready in time for my own wedding can I
use this anytime soon or can you email
me when I can sign up that's when we
knew we had a winning product and that's
when we committed to doing it 100% wow
that's exciting that's like the full-on
process before taking the jump is a good
way to do it so you know we we see a lot
of wedding startups applying to us
there's lots out there the we're in an
age where retailers generally are
struggling so what do you think it is
about zola that's made it so successful
so when we were thinking about zora as
an idea we thought that
we could produce a product that was
different and that users really loved
but just as important to that was it was
important to me that we have a business
model that works and I think that has
been our biggest competitive advantage
and that's the reason why we've been
able to survive and thrive where most
other wedding startups have have closed
in the years that we've been around and
this was really based from my experience
at gilt so I worked at gilt during the
first four years of the business in
product and saw a lot about what worked
really well to drive that huge growth
from zero dollars in revenue to over six
hundred million dollars in revenue in
four years and I also saw what
ultimately did not work which led to the
decline and meant that it could never
really be a profitable sustainable
company and we've looked at what are
those problems that guilt which are
typical ecommerce problems and how can
we solve them at zola so for example the
way the things we learned were one in
e-commerce returns the silent killer you
hear laughs from anyone who's worked in
an e-commerce business you don't quite
realize that when you're first starting
until you're halfway into the business
you're like oh these returns are brutal
to the business model and the way that
we were able to address that and Soula
is through this feature where we don't
actually send anything until people tell
us they actually want to receive it and
through the registry people can do
virtual returns so they exchange things
through our app or through our site
before they ever get it shipped out to
them and that has meant we have
virtually no returns one of the other
killers in e-commerce is inventory and
we were able to address that by building
our back-end technology that enables us
to dropship products from our partner
warehouses directly to
our couples and by not taking in product
into our warehouse and then shipping it
out again that meant that we were able
to be much more capital efficient and
just ultimately about a more sustainable
business than the normal ecommerce
business and the last thing I'll say
around ecommerce businesses is that
they're very hard to forecast and
project and and to drive people down
that checkout conversion funnel at gilt
actually one of the things that worked
really well to drive demand and drive
people to check out was that we saw when
you're selling designer brands that
people love at 80% off for 24 hours only
in limited inventory that really drives
demand but the flip side of that is it's
very hard to predict and forecast
so at zola we were thinking about how do
we still drive demand intent but have a
more for castable business and when it's
more for castable it's more manageable
and the way the reason actually why we
are excited about the wedding registry a
business and the model we were adopting
is that for the most part when people
get married you kind of set up you have
to pick a wedding registry and when you
go to a wedding you kind of have to buy
off the registry that is part of a ready
demand that is going to happen by a
certain deadline which is your wedding
date and so that demand intent was built
in to the idea of a wedding registry and
that was something that was one of the
reasons we wanted to do this the other
thing that was important to us was
because people sign up for a wedding
registry seven months before their
wedding date and they start adding
things to their registry we can very
clearly predict a forecast what we're
going to sell seven months to one year
in advance and then we can manage our
business to make sure we have those
items in stock available for couples
when they want to ship them and in doing
so have a better user experience but
also a better business model and I think
that solving the the user experience and
the business model together is what has
allowed us to to be successful in the
wedding space amazing so I'm going to
take you back in time back to the very
early days of the company and I love
asking this question because practically
every founder I speak to has some kind
of crazy story around this so asking you
about your first seed around and how
that came about and what are your crazy
stories on there oh I have some crazy
stories so I speak to a lot of founders
and have really learned every seed round
is unique and ours is no different so
I'll see Ron was a bit different because
because I had worked at gilt groupe for
four years before Zola and had worked
very closely with the founder of guilt
his name is Kevin Ryan and he is a
serial entrepreneur in New York he
founded gilt Business Insider and
co-founded Munger and he was excited to
work with myself and my co-founder Nobu
again so when we talked about starting
this wedding company he said I would
love to work with you I will give you
the seed funding and we can just get
started and while you were here many
people are like that sounds like a
really good seed round situation I will
have to agree and say it was great but
it wasn't as easy as it sounds because
because it wasn't like it was just
handed on a silver platter the reason I
had that opportunity to have that offer
was because I had worked with Kevin for
four long years for very intense startup
years and I had essentially slugged my
guts out for him
for four long years and that was the
reason I got that seed offer so while
many people are like oh you didn't even
you know you didn't really raise a seed
round I'm like I was raising it for four
years
so that that was our seed round but the
funny story is when I was negotiating
the seed seed round with Kevin I was
actually in Ireland because I had to go
and get my visa because I'm a from
Australia and so I was in Ireland I was
on a hike and for those of you who had
Game of Thrones fans it's like I was
like essentially at Winterfell hiking it
was pouring with rain there was no cover
anywhere and I was on the phone like
trying to negotiate terms with him and
we got there but it was yeah it was
interesting and what was it like working
with him as an investor and somebody
that you were working with it's
fantastic and he because I've worked
with him now for close to 10 years he
has been essentially like a coach and a
mentor and you know in many ways a very
active investor and co-founder in the
business and so it's great to have
someone who is operated at this point in
New York for decades who has seen many
many businesses who can give me a
reality check and do so from the
operator entrepreneur perspective which
is very different from the VC investor
perspective okay so so now coming back
up to present day where you've gone from
from negotiating seed rounds in the rain
to raising 140 million dollars how's the
pitch changed how is it how has it
changed how you talk to investors what
mistakes have you made along the way
any advice for these ladies yes I wish
someone had told me in the early rounds
what I'm about to share here which is
you know in in some of the later rounds
when I would pitch in partner meetings
which were inevitably at that time all
dudes and maybe one woman in the room
like 20 dudes one woman I would always
ask you do you see differences between
the way I pitch and the way male
founders pitch and every time I hear a
very consistent response which is
guys come into the pitch they bang their
fists on the table and they swear that
this is gonna be a billion dollar
business they have no doubt that it's
gonna be a billion dollar business which
is funny because every single guy has no
doubt it's going to be a billion dollar
business and women just don't really do
that they and and certainly I didn't so
my pitch you know I have had investors
tell me you're just more modest and more
factual and not really as aggressive as
a lot of the male founders pitching and
and so I've been thinking about this a
lot over the years and what I've tried
to do is really verbalize externally
during the pitch the conviction that I
feel internally but in the early rounds
never had enough confidence or enough
guts I would say to really be banging my
fists on the table because they thought
in my mind at that point was always you
know there's a small chance that may not
be a billion-dollar business so I don't
know if I want to say this there's no
doubt this is gonna but it turns out
that actually I feel very strongly about
it so I should just say that and the
funny anecdote here is more recently I
had a guy pitching to me that he was
building a trillion dollar business all
right wait are we there though I guess
so right I have to upgrade my pitch so
you've mentioned your co-founder a
couple of times how did you you know how
does the relationship work between the
two of you how has that changed over
time how do you complement each other
yeah Nobu who is my co-founder is the
best and we love working together
because and part of it is we have worked
together for many years before starting
Zola and the reason we wanted to start
solar together was because we knew from
our past work we were able to create
great award-winning products together
and there was something so rewarding and
fulfilling about that that we wanted to
do that again and so he is I think the
best
design thinker in the world he is our
chief design officer and leads product
and user experience design and and in
the early days when it was just me and
him he would focus on product and design
and creative and I would focus on
everything else over the years he has
continued to really manage our design
vision and product rollout and and I've
tried to replace myself more and more in
each function that I was initially
responsible for but having someone that
you trust fully who knows you really
well
who knows that your weaknesses and
strengths has made all the difference in
the world amazing ok so we just have a
couple more minutes so to wrap up what's
the the one biggest piece of advice that
you wish you'd known when you started
that you can share with the audience
today
my advice to founders is always a piece
of advice that I got when I was first
starting zola and have I think it was
the most valuable piece of advice which
is before you really decide to commit to
an idea for your startup to to think
about how you're gonna spend at least
the next 10 years of your life focused
on this one thing and that's if
everything goes well but you are gonna
be living breathing working pretty much
24/7 on this one thing and your most
valuable asset is your time so is this
the best way that you want to be
investing your time for the next decade
because if it's not the best investment
of your time maybe you should think
about another idea and other team
something else but to really have a
commitment to yourself before you bring
anyone else on your journey and once
you're able to think about that and
commit to yourself that this is the only
thing you want to be doing then you're
ready to go
alright Shannon thank you very much this
has been an excellent
you
you